my name is jose miguel guzman i am
participating in the council on
population growth and this year is very
important because this year the
population will reach the seven billion
and that means that there is a lot of
challenges that the world has in knowing
what are the implications of this figure
and worried implication of the fact that
most of the population growth in the
future will occur in developing
countries what we can do about that
first there are many options but the
most of the the most important option is
that people have the capacity to take
decisions intervale with their lives
particularly to provide women with the
means to decide freely and informed
about the number of children they want
to have this is the most important
mission and that governments can take is
giving the people the opportunity to the
tape decision by their own that that
means that there are options but also we
need to know about what are the severity
situation in different countries because
the situation is not the same we have
countries in which you have a very high
fertility and that means that in most of
them in those countries the population
will be growing very fast and also we
know that if some countries most of the
growth will occur in urban areas so
there will be many cities in the world
particularly in Africa in Asia and will
be doubling the population in less than
25 years so that mean that the
government's national governments and
local governments need to plan for that
growth